well in post-war Germany had a man at a
savings in konrad adenauer and probably
played a tremendous role in the
clarification and getting rid of Nazism
and so forth in post-world War France
charles de gaulle also played a big role
and in great britain to winston
churchill so we know that older people
can be very very important in our
country we also picked a father figure
after the war not quite as old who his
name was Dwight Eisenhower and in 1994 i
guess it was we had Bob Dole 73 run for
president and there were people at that
time that said well maybe he wouldn't've
out his term if he were elected well
he's still alive and it's long since he
would have in fact left political office
so I think the most important thing is
function not age probably not a bad idea
to pick a good vice president and in
this country we've had eight presidents
vice presidents who become president so
because largely because of
assassinations rather than through
natural death but it's certainly not a
bad idea to pick a strong vice president
but I see no reason why capable
functioning older people shouldn't run
for president just as they've done in
Europe and have done in societies from
time immemorial well I think that we
didn't test out an hour we didn't test
de Gaulle I'm not sure there should be
any hard and fast rule on that as Reagan
said to mod Dale during their debate he
wasn't going to hold mondale's youth and
inexperience against him so I don't know
if I think we get a little too
simple-minded on such matters